mourners queuing in their hundreds to
pay respects to one of the government
soldiers killed in an attack by forces
loyal to warlord Khalifa Haftar he loved
men died and nearly a hundred were
wounded on Sunday as they defended the
small town of Abu Ghraib 80 kilometers
east of Misrata
they included Mohammed Abu zaid's 23
year old son Abdul Aziz who volunteered
to help repel the half tower attack I
have another 12 sons and I would
sacrifice them all in this struggle
against a man who wants to be a dictator
these images were put on social media
it's thought that at least 12 of
half-dollars men were killed in the
fighting the attack took everyone by
surprise we know there was a ceasefire
and we weren't expecting an attack there
was a lot of firepower
he suffered shrapnel wounds to the head
I chest and hand the museum on Tripoli
Street tells the story of Misrata spree
vyas battles in the 2011 revolution and
more recently against ISIL in Libya the
fighters of Misrata are known for their
bravery it's what saved the city nine
years ago and was a key factor in the
downfall of Muammar Gaddafi but the
people here also know what the cost can
be when you oppose a dictator
in the 2011 revolution Gaddafi's forces
occupied the city for three months 2,800
people were killed and more than 13,000
were wounded but it was the men from is
rata who captured the Libyan leader
insert and brought the war against him
to a close here they believe the warlord
Khalifa Haftar is just like Gaddafi he
wants to rule Libya the same way as
Gaddafi but we fought against a
dictatorship which controlled us for 40
years and we won't allow that to happen
again
few here thought the sacrifices of the
Revolution would have to be made again
and few here are willing to predict when
the day will come when Misrata no longer
has to mourn the deaths of its young men
Tony Berkley al-jazeera Misrata